Invidia can't really push back the 1180
any longer and so the gtx 1180 is going
to come out really soon
[Music]
welcome to horace hobbies so for the
past couple of weeks there have been a
lot of leaks rumors and speculation
around the release date of the gtx 1180
from July 30th all the way to not till
2019 however recently gamer melon got
some news from an insider source who
told him about the release dates of the
new 1100 series so according to this
leak the gtx 1180 is supposed to come
out on August 30th followed by the gtx
1170 and something called the gtx 1180
plus on september 30th and finally the
1160 on october 30th and this matches
perfectly with the reveal at the hot
chips conference on August 20th and
launch schedule makes sense as well
because all the main chords of the 1100
series will be out before the holiday
season of 2018 like I said in video
would do in order to maximize sales and
profit but before this we actually heard
another leak from gamer mode that
suggested that the gtx 1180 would
actually come out on July 30th well that
doesn't seem to be happening so why is
this leak different and actually going
to happen first of all I believe that
leak was true and that in video was
actually planning to release the gtx
1180 on July 30th considering that GD
dr6 memory production already started in
June so that timeframe would make sense
but suddenly a Taiwanese add-in board
partner who could be gigabyte returned
300,000 GPUs backed in video because he
had too much inventory and with 10
series sales already not doing well for
NVIDIA this looked abundant inventory of
the 10 series foreign video and this is
probably what led to the delay that
we're seeing right now
so that's why that leak didn't turn out
to be true so this leak could be fake -
right well here's why I believe that it
is going to be legitimate first of all
the 10 series is over 2 years old and
all the consumers who wanted the 10
series already bought it
and the people who haven't already
bought it are waiting for the 11 series
because they prefer not to buy almost
outdated
Tagg and this has led to a low sales
numbers for the 10 series for NVIDIA and
this can be seen in the really low sales
report for the second quarter of this
year so it doesn't make sense to try to
revive a dying series and push along
farther when they already had the
technology ready for the eleventh series
and considering that it would
significantly boost their sales as well
secondly NVIDIA has abundant inventory
of the 10 series because of
overproduction and so by now they have
definitely stopped producing the 10
series especially considering that they
have avoided inventory of it there were
rumors that production of GP 102 stopped
way back in February so by now the
production of a 10 series has definitely
come to a halt so right now they have a
limited amount of cards to sell and
they're trying to boost their sales by
lowering prices and offering good
discounts in order to get rid of all of
their inventory and this strategy is
definitely driving a lot more sales for
in video for example just a couple of
days ago you could get a gtx 1080 for
$450 which is $150 less than MSRP so for
anyone who doesn't really care about the
newest tech and just wants good
performance
the 10th series is still a really great
option and so if they're finding such
deals they're definitely going to buy it
thus Nvidia is running through their
tensors inventory very quickly and if
the 11 series doesn't launch soon they
will run out of the 10 series and they
won't have anything to sell overall they
have been strategically offering GPUs
for better prices that itself shows that
there is something big coming because
Nvidia is trying to get rid of their
inventory as soon as possible also 10
series production is always stock so at
this rate they will run out of the 10
series very quickly so the eleventh
series must be coming soon to take its
place thirdly GDD our sixth memory
production has already started so I'm
not sure why SK Hynix would be pumping
out that many gt-r 6 memory chips unless
Nvidia was using them to produce their
new 11 Series cards finally some people
are suggesting that in video we'll wait
till 2019 to least eleven hundred series
but that doesn't really make sense
because why would in video release the
1100 series right after all the holiday
sales of 20
tene just ended instead it makes a lot
more sense for nvidia to release the
1100 series a couple of months earlier
in order to take advantage of all the
holiday sales overall nvidia can't
really push back to released eight of
the eleven nurseries any longer because
of how of the sales of the ten series
isn't doing well due to its age high
anticipation for the 1100 series GT dr6
memory production have already started
limited inventory of the 10 series and
finally to avoid missing out on all the
holiday sales of 2018 thus I believe
that the main cards at the 1100 series
were stirred the 1180 at eleven seventy
and eleven sixty will indeed come out
before the beginning of november but not
just what i think what do you guys think
are you guys going to be waiting to buy
a leavener series card or are you just
looking to get a good 10 series card for
a great price make sure to comment down
below what you guys think because I do
read all my comments I'm curious as to
what you guys think so make sure to post
your thoughts also if you guys like this
video then make sure drop a like and
consider subscribing if you would like
to see more videos just like this one
but until next time bye
[Music]